before you died
[Music]
so yes if you work out strictly for
appearance-based reasons you are fat
phobic
[Music]
also known as grizzly
here's a man that man that saw God
himself in the eye and said I will
surpass him hell yeah
most aesthetic fish
in the past not actually a hallway he's
standing in he's standing here
oh God
so sometimes you stumble on a channel on
YouTube and it's this pure gold
kiriakers have a look egg I I murdered
that kiriakos Kappa kulak sorry I am
subscribed and is not logged in this guy
has been uploading YouTube videos for
nine years but recently he's been blown
well not that recently but he's been
blowing up for the One Clip maybe you've
seen it it's so funny let me if you
haven't God bless you it's my one of my
favorite YouTube clips here it comes
yeah
yeah
oh it's so good I love this guy spotting
him like what is he gonna do there's no
way he could even go near those weights
man is lifting a [ __ ] car at the
moment by the way he's just there like
quick sponsor segment you ever wonder
why Naruto runs like this that's because
he's on that Sage Mode baby look at that
do you feel collide with Naruto the only
Naruto collab that matters is the G fuel
narrow to collab I've been drinking this
for a week I I almost already finished
the Box
[Music]
favorite flavors after PewDiePie of
course I didn't know what it the flavor
was I just knew I really liked it but
it's white peaches sweet Citrus and the
taste of pomelo fruit all mixed just all
wonderful things
I love G fuel I've been drinking it
regardless if they were paying me it's
the best drink try it out I recommend it
it saves you money and it supports your
favorite creator
it's me right so while you check out use
the code PewDiePie that way not only do
you support me but you get 30 up so yeah
time to stock up also of course if
you're extra Nihon get the PewDiePie Uso
flavor it takes like God himself also
for the record I keep getting people
like oh it's caffeine number that we
have a caffeine free version don't miss
out on that it tastes equally as good so
yeah what are you waiting for try it out
try out other craters flavors It's a
Wonderful Community it's a wonderful
time thank you g fuels for sponsoring
this video
do you feel I love you I love you [ __ ]
the more you watch this clip the funnier
it gets because it's like the quacking
the fact that he's like shocked at his
own strength at the end
he's terrified of his own power my
favorite part is when the skinny guy
goes for the handshake and he almost get
lunch
look at it look at it
you think there's plates are Sweden
branded no he's lifting the weight of
Sweden he has a Sweden can confirm oh
God it's so good I love I love this
channel I love YouTube this is the
reason why since he's uploaded for nine
years it's impressive to see his journey
of the of improvement like this is all
love and respect but for this man but
yeah the thing is he posts these workout
videos fine right but he posts them with
absolutely zero there's some context but
very little context which leads the
comments to fill in the gap which makes
it so funny the comments on his videos
are the funniest
don't try to understand the ways of the
Lord he's beyond the moral realm
boxing training
slice into Splurge your workout with
some boxing so strong his shadow has
become his own hit
oh God I love this one this combo could
easily defeat Achilles it not only has
the dexterity of Achilles he has the
strength of Hector's horses this man is
Unstoppable
beautiful he has this one video called
screams it's exactly what you expect
oh
mama yeah boy
[Applause]
yes
foreign
in the gym is generally frowned upon
right it's either pretentious losers who
are we're just boasting their strength
which has nothing to do with it or it's
seen as some sort of thick-headed grunt
low level IQ move but in reality in the
terms of grisly curiakos it is the most
intellectual thing you could possibly do
because it everyone knows screaming
increases adrenaline which makes you
lift even further and when you are on
his level you are lifting on levels that
no other man Has Lifted before
what is the tape doing
[Laughter]
screaming in the gym it's the most
intellectual thing you could ever do and
that's the only right opinion
he didn't vanish he just started his
cardio session
cardio is cringe he can only blow it up
Men's Health stop hitting up this cringy
Marvel steroid steroid boys get this man
on the cover of GQ ASAP I was afraid of
the retaliation I know the power of
patriarchy I know what men can do when
they're angry
all right
it's the best video on YouTube this
video is life-changing informative
inspiring heartwarming useful calming
enjoyable other me and the boys working
out together over Zoom looks like should
only look like this
so this move I think it's supposed to be
a squad he just came up with his own
workouts I assume I never heard of
zerica's rock shrugs nobody else is
doing it but nobody else could hold
force 70 like that and shrug like 470
kilos that's more than some cars surely
mine is lifting half the aren't they get
this man a gorilla tape
you know what they say that pregnant
women can lift the car if their baby is
in danger or something like that I don't
know what they say and that's not it
imagine what kiriakos then could lift if
he was pregnant huh so he weighed
himself which is uh
kiryakus never goes faster than the
speed because faster than that speed
would be considered cardio a cardinal
sin I say it goes to weigh himself as
you do after a workout
what is his weight
oh
blood God blood God
give me your strength
I like how it included he's full of
cardio routiness
yes this man is Newton's Laws of Motion
the f equals mass times acceleration the
F stands for full this man has full
power he's reached it he is also
surprisingly flexible like look at this
dude
bro I can't do that
[Music]
he's the ultimate
Warrior
creators would tremble in fear for this
man I wanted to make a joke but it's
actually insane yeah
dude the cows always crack me up on his
videos I love it I could watch his
videos all day they give me so much
motivation I want to try his workout
maybe I'll do that at the end of the
video he's doing this one exercise for
strong abs
mantis crushes himself this would kill
any person
holy [ __ ]
how many plates is that one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve ah come on we didn't get
the 13. let's just say he's still
stacking more to this day I know right
it's a great X7 core string huh I don't
know if that's true but [ __ ] it I gotta
respect the man too he doesn't just like
it's not just one of those show-off
channels that only post their personal
records you know he also showed uh some
week some sense of weakness
foreign
[Music]
that's pretty rare especially on YouTube
yeah this video is played backwards he
was just waking up from
okay yeah I got it wrong my bad
absolute Legend I want to try it I want
to try it I only have dumbbells so this
will be completely pointless but I want
to try out I want to taste of what it's
like to work out like God himself we're
here at the PewDiePie gym attempting to
replicate God himself
bloat I don't have olympic plates I have
dumbbells should I even try is there no
point
no I want to try I want to try what he
does so the exercise he does I think
it's for squatting but he's somehow
transformed it into like a
back I don't know what it is he's
working out but I would assume like if
you were squatting who cares but I would
it would be like holding its center
right
because that's what you're doing
the point the point is he's made up his
own work exercise
and made it better don't know how to do
this with dumbbells but like if I had to
do it with dumbbells it would be like
this but that's not what it's doing so
it doesn't matter so if I had to copy
him I would
give it
[Applause]
I miss
okay Marge yeah take the other dumbbell
and put it on top of me if I die it will
be an honorable death
okay put it on the tripod
how the [ __ ] would I do this
is why you died
[Music]
what am I doing I'm just gonna injure
myself I don't know how he does it
no way I'm stronger on my rider let's do
it like that okay
and we just gotta get this on top
that's not easy
just setting up his workout is a workout
I'm gonna move back a little bit it's
probably just me furiously breathing at
the in the
in the mic okay
[Music]
[Applause]
and don't all I also don't want to die
actually I do want to die never mind I
don't know okay here we go
this is how God intended working
I mean if I can just do one
I need the tape Marzia he has taper on
them
I should do it
okay you can't be here it's too
dangerous
come on Nikki
that ought to do it
here we go
I gotta make a sound
you're just copying me
seems like I'm making fun of him I'm not
that's his ab workout too and just
crushing himself
I wish we could do that now actually
okay crush me
[Applause]
[ __ ] stuck my microphone
oh
okay just put the other put the other
one on top oh my God
okay this is my idea that board I will I
board I actually how do I get out of
this
I didn't I didn't think that far
now come back
no
ah this is why you don't even imitate
the Gods
ah I haven't committed a crime the crime
against
okay I've never been so humbled in my
life
I committed a severe life of judgment I
apologize
I give up
undefeated
all right so remember check out and
subscribe kariakos kappakul like
greatest Channel on YouTube also check
out the new G fuel Sage Mode flavor it's
out for 30 off if you enter the code
PewDiePie support me and get cheaper G
fuel it's the greatest drink of all time
I love it and that's it see you in the
next video brofist